[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés organes
mancini bonjour oriane gentiment et
cette semaine notre invité est bastien
lachaud député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis bonjour à vous bonjour
à vous et cette semaine un rapport a
fait du bruit celui de la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur la sphère
benalla les sénateurs pointe des
dysfonctionnements majeurs au sommet de
l'état l'exécutif et les parlementaires
de la majorité ont riposté parlant de
rapports très politique et dénonçant un
non respect de la séparation des
pouvoirs le parlement unis face à la
montée de l'antisémitisme gérard larcher
et richard ferrand se sont rendus
ensemble au mémorial de la shoah
accompagné du président de la république
la question de la pénalisation de
l'antisionisme a été mise sur la table
par les députés instaurer un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne c'est une des
revendications des gilet jaune la france
insoumise en a fait une proposition de
loi cette semaine dans le cadre de sa
niche parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale mais sans grande surprise le
texte a été retoqué par la majorité et
on commence la semaine avec le sénat qui
a remis son rapport sur la sphère
benalla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était le temps fort de la semaine
après six mois de travaux 50 heures
d'audition la commission denquête a
rendu publiques ses conclusions sur la
sphère benalla et elles sont accablantes
pour l'elysée la commission pointe des
dysfonctionnements majeurs et propose 13
recommandation pour y remédier et
mickaël spielberg
après six mois d'investigations et 34
auditions les sénateurs ont rendu leur
rapport de la commission d' enquête sur
la sphère benalla au fil des 160 pages
il estime que la sécurité du président
de la république a été mise à mal par
l'inexpérience et l'omniprésence
d'alexandre benalla auprès d' emmanuel
macron la thèse de la faute de l'homme
isolé s'est effacé au profit du
dysfonctionnement d'une institution qui
a rendu possibles ces multiples
situations normales allant jusqu à
affecter la sécurité du président de la
république pour les sénateurs des
dysfonctionnements graves sont apparus
au plus haut niveau de l'état
en témoigne la sphère des passeports
diplomatiques leurs attributions et
surtout leur récupération auprès de l'ex
chargé de mission à la présidence de la
république
en conséquence la commission multiplie
les recommandations prévenir et
sanctionner les conflits d'intérêts
parmi les collaborateurs des cabinets
garantir des standards de sécurité élevé
pour le président de la république et le
premier ministre
mieux encadrer l'usagé des passeports
diplomatiques et de service
mieux réguler les promotions dans les
réserves de la gendarmerie nationale en
découlent
treize propositions concrètes dont près
de la moitié concerne le fonctionnement
de l'exécutif notamment en matière de
recrutement d'encadrement et de contrôle
des collaborateurs de l'elysée
les sénateurs souhaitent aussi renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle du parlement
sur les services de la présidence de la
république
enfin la commission réclame des suites
judiciaires à son travail en cause les
mensonges d'alexandre benalla les
omissions de certains collaborateurs de
l'elysée lors des auditions
nous proposons au président du sénat et
au bureau du sénat de saisir le parquet
c'est clair premièrement pour monsieur
benalla écrase en parlant de faux
témoignages deuxièmement nous demandons
que pour les collaborateurs de l'elysée
le parquet soit saisie visé le directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
patrick strzoda alexis kohler le
secrétaire général de l'elysée
et lionel lavergne le commandant du
groupe de sécurité de la présidence de
la république alors bastien la chaux que
retenez-vous de ce rapport le sénat
parle de dysfonctionnements majeurs
c'est aussi votre avis oui c'est la
démonstration qu'il y avait bien un
système à la tête de l'état qui a
organisé les actions de monsieur benalla
et surtout sa protection après les
effets de la place de la contrescarpe
donc il faut que toute la lumière soit
faite le sénat a enquêté
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas pu le
faire parce que la majorité a torpillé
la commission denquête qui s'était qui
s'était mise en place et on voit bien
que cela aurait été aussi utile que
notre assemblée puisse se prononcer sur
ces sur ces questions là mais en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y
avait un système avec les plus hauts
responsables de l'église est impliqué
dedans et peut-être monsieur macron le
sénat parle de dysfonctionnements mais
ne parlent pas d' affaire d'état ou de
scandales d'état il ne va pas assez loin
selon vous écouter à partir du moment où
un système se met en place avec des
hauts fonctionnaires qui mentent ou
qu'ils mentent par omission
devant une commission d enquête du du
sénat que la sécurité du président est
mise en péril
je ne sais pas en quoi cela n'est pas
une affaire d'état vous parlez de deux
systèmes la commission a pointé du doigt
les omissions les contradictions de deux
des principaux collaborateurs
collaborateur du chef de l'état alexis
colère et un patrick strzoda est ce que
pour vous on est dans une affaire qui
peut déstabiliser le pouvoir de fait le
pouvoir est déstabilisé depuis juillet
cela devait être une affaire d t elle
continue depuis maintenant huit mois
évidemment que la réforme
constitutionnelle du président de la
république a été bloquée à cause de
cette de cette affaire donc oui bien sûr
que le signe que le pouvoir est
déstabilisée et il faut que toute la
lumière soit faite ce qui est encore
loin d'être le cas vu que toutes les
semaines nous apprenons de
nouveau scandale lié à monsieur pénale à
travers la commission demande des
poursuites judiciaires 1 contre
alexander benn a accusé d'avoir menti
sous serment les sénateurs en raison et
bien sûr on ne peut pas dans ce pays
expliqué que le parlement a le pouvoir
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
que des membres de l'exécutif mentent
impunément devancé devancé commission
denquête emmanuel macron a vraiment une
responsabilité dans ces dans cette
affaire les les éléments dans le rapport
pour en attester sont faibles au minimum
il ne sait pas ce qui se passe chez lui
et c'est quand même gênant pour un chef
de l'état de ne pas savoir ce qui se
passe
ne serait-ce qu'à l'elysée alors la
riposte de l'exécutif ne s'est pas fait
attendre dans les minutes qui ont suivi
la présentation du rapport benjamin
griveaux a dénoncé des contre vérités et
le lendemain c'est le premier ministre
qui est monté au front attaquant les
sénateurs sur la séparation des pouvoirs
en écoute edouard philippe
personne ne peut être surpris que le
sénat fasse de la politique c'est
naturel je crois que ça ne surprend
personne
peut-être peut-on peut-être peut-on
exprimer une déception lorsque des
sénateurs qui je n'en doute pas le sens
de l'état mais connaissent le principe
de séparation des pouvoirs de cette
façon alors scène inhabituelle un
edouard philippe sur le perron de
matignon pour réagir à ce rapport
qu'est-ce que ça traduit selon vous de
l'embarras au minimum quand on le canton
l'écoutent mais surtout c'est assez
facile d'utiliser la séparation des
pouvoirs pour critiquer le sénat mais le
gouvernement ne ne se gênent pas lui
pour balayer la séparation des pouvoirs
quand il a une majorité aux ordres et à
qui ils imposent tout et son contraire
sans sans difficulté donc moi je trouve
que monsieur philippe était très très
embarrassé de ce rapport parce que il
sait que le rapport pointe de réalisme
fonctionnement et de réels problèmes au
plus haut sommet de l'état
alors les mots du premier ministre ont
fait vivement réagir les sénateurs de
gauche comme de droite ils estiment que
le sénat est dans son rôle et il pointe
la fébrilité de l'exécutif jonathan
dupriez
un bras de fer s'engage entre l'exécutif
et le sénat après la publication du
rapport sur la sphère benalla edouard
philippe dénonce une appréciation très
politique et reproche ouvertement à la
chambre haute de méconnaître la
séparation des pouvoirs
il est critique balayée par la
commission des lois dans un communiqué
le président de la commission et les
deux co rapporteurs ne commande pas les
commentaires ils rappellent leur profond
attachement au principe de séparation
des pouvoirs qu'ils ont scrupuleusement
respectée il importe aussi pour la
maturité de la démocratie que la mission
fondamentale du parlement dans ses
pouvoirs de contrôle soient pleinement
respectés
pour le premier ministre le sénat n'a
pas à se prononcer sur l'organisation
interne de l'elysée mais pour les
sénateurs des faits avérés prouvent des
dysfonctionnements majeurs au sommet de
l'état pour eux la commission d' enquête
est donc dans son rôle quand on est dans
le fonctionnement normal des
institutions le gouvernement et surtout
l'elysée aurait été bien mieux inspiré
de reconnaître qu'il y avait eu au
départ à un dysfonctionnement avec
monsieur benalla venue s'occuper de
sécurité en prenant le pas sur les
policiers les gendarmes et que les
choses étaient recadre il s'agit du
sénat qui exerce son rôle
constitutionnel de contrôle de
l'exécutif
cette réaction du gouvernement et pour
d'autres un signe de fébrilité du
pouvoir dans la sphère benalla si le
gouvernement n'accepte plus
finalement un contre-pouvoir puisque
c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit
nous sommes une partie du parlement mais
qui n'est pas dans le sens souhaité par
l'exécutif ci ne pas aller dans le sens
de l'exécutif c'est devenir totalement
critiquable par celui ci est bien il ya
effectivement un danger
attention la démocrature cette attaque
frontale du premier ministre survient
dans un contexte particulièrement tendu
entre l'exécutif et le palais du
luxembourg mise à l'écart du grand débat
les sénateurs avaient été choqués par la
remise en question du rôle même du sénat
dans la lettre aux français emmanuel
macron alors bastien la chaux est ce que
le sénat est selon vous dans son rôle
dans cette affaire et si ce ne sont pas
les assemblées qui contrôle exécutif qui
contrôle l'exécutif c'est bien ça le
problème c'est une nouvelle fois une
dérive supplémentaire
l'autoritarisme de ce régime qui ne
supporte pas la contradiction qui ne
supporte pas les oppositions qui
s'arrogent les pleins pouvoirs et qui
dès qu' il y a quelqu'un qui osent
s'affronter à lui essaye de le mettre au
pas et de le décrédibiliser et cela est
très inquiétant pour pour la démocratie
vaut le sénat est dans son rôle n'y a
pas de remise en cause de la séparation
et bien sûr que non il n'ya pas de
séparation de n'y a pas de problème avec
la séparation des pouvoirs
sinon qu'ils contrôlent si ce n'est pas
le sénat qui contre l'elysée personne ne
contrôle de l'elysée
nous avons un souverain un monarque
présidentiel complètement irresponsable
de ses actes devant personne ça serait
c'est terrifiant en fait cette idée de
se dire qu'un homme seul a tous les
pouvoirs et que personne n'a le droit de
le contrôler pour vous on entre dans un
bras de fer entre le sénat l'exécutif
écoutez pour je ne sais pas si ça sera
un bras de fer je ne sais pas jusqu'où
veux veux aller le sénat mettrait
clairement aujourd'hui l'exécutif doit
entendre qu'il n'est pas tout puissant
et qu'il ne veut pas tout faire tout
seul sinon en effet la démocratie est en
péril et c'est l'autoritarisme du régime
qu'il faut questionner on va passer un
autre thème le parlement unis cette
semaine face à la montée de
l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stop à l'antisémitisme le message a été
martelé toute la semaine dans une forme
d'union sacrée politique mardi des
rassemblements se sont tenus dans toute
la france
à paris tous les partis se sont
retrouvés dans une dénonciation commune
des faits survenus ces dernières
semaines et le président de la
république s'est rendu au mémorial de la
shoah avec les présidents des deux
assemblées et richard ferrand et gérard
larcher
écoutez les deux hommes il ya tout un
symbole le président de la république
nous a rejoint et ce triptyque de la
république l'exécutif
les deux assemblées c'est d'abord un
signe de la république en direction de
nos compatriotes juifs la france et leur
pays et à france a besoin d'eux comme
nous avons besoin d'autres composantes
dans notre pays nous sommes là pour dire
que notre communauté nationale a besoin
de tout le monde et que les l'abject
insanités que représente l'antisémitisme
n'a pas de place dans notre république
et si nous étions là ensemble c'était
pour dire notre détermination à ne
jamais céder
c'est un bon signal pour vous bastien la
choque les présidents des deux
assemblées se soit affiché au côté du
président de la république au mémorial
de la shoah face à l'antisémitisme comme
face à toute forme de racisme de
discrimination là l'ensemble de
de la société doit se mobiliser et doit
faire front commun
vous savez ce qui fait république c'est
le principe fondamental selon lequel
chaque personne doit être l'égal de
l'autre et que l'égalité est le
fondement de la république des citoyens
et à partir du moment où le fondement
c'est l'égalité il ne peut y avoir de
discrimination acceptable dans notre
dans notre république c'est ça le
message qui je pense a été envoyée mardi
soir sur les rassemblements de mardi la
france insoumise a annoncé sa
participation à cette a1 dit pourquoi
nous ne vaut pas à annoncer notre
participation tardivement
nous n'avons il ya eu un quiproquo avec
le ps qui n'a pas vraiment essayer de
s'assurer que nous signons l'appel
évidemment nous avons signé l'appel dès
que cela nous déclare elle nous a été
présentée et nous avons toujours dit que
nous participerions assez à ces
rassemblements
d'où vient ce soupçon qui vous est
collée par par vos adversaires d'une
forme de complaisance avec
l'antisémitisme à députés de la majorité
cette semaine encore a dit que les
racines de votre mouvement était
antisémite comment vous jugé ces
soupçons ignoble ignoble parce que je
tiens quand même à dire notre mouvement
s'inscrit dans la grande révolution dans
les idées de la grande révolution de
1789 et à cette époque là c'est
maximilien robespierre qui a réussi à
obtenir le droit de vote
justement de nos concitoyens juifs qui
étaient exclus du droit de vote à cette
époque là et quand c'est notre mouvement
s'inscrit dans les traditions
républicaines justement d'égalité
absolue de tous les citoyens et je
trouve que ce député a fait preuve d'une
tentative d'instrumentalisation de la
question de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme qui n'est pas digne de
cette question c'est parce qu'au fait
que jean luc mélenchon a eu un tweet pas
très clair quand il a condamné les
allées ces insultes contre alain
finkielkraut le week-end dernier
en quoi son tweet était-il pas clair il
a condamné les insultes jean luc
mélenchon a constamment condamné tout
acte antisémite pourquoi la soude un set
cette polémique
si ce n'est uniquement par
instrumentalisation est ce que vraiment
quand on a besoin que toute la
communauté nationale soit unie contre
ces discriminations contre ces racistes
contre l'antisémitisme créer de faux
procès je pense qu'il y a trop
d'incidents trop d'antisémite dans ce
pays il n'y a pas besoin d'en inventer
des faux pourquoi ce faux procès alors
comme vous dites c'est à eux qu'il faut
poser la question
moi je pense qu'il s'agit d'
instrumentalisation politique je le
condamne parce que ce sujet est trop
grave pour que l'on puisse se permettre
de procéder avec de telles méthodes
abjectes
alors outre les condamnations bastien la
chaux la question posée par les faits
survenus cette semaine et notamment
l'agression envers le philosophe alain
finkielkraut est celle de l'antisionisme
doit-il être condamné au même titre que
l'antisémitisme
faut-il une nouvelle loi pour cela mardi
un député de la majorité a soutenu un
texte en ce sens mais la majorité et
l'exécutif s'y sont montrés défavorables
mais finalement mercredi devant le crif
le président la république a annoncé que
l'antisionisme soir est tout même plus
sévèrement punies explications laszlo
gelabert l'ensemble de l'europe et la
quasi-totalité des démocraties
occidentales est confronté à une
résurgence de l'antisémitisme sans doute
inédite depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale un constat alarmant dressé par
emmanuel macron au dîner annuel du
conseil représentatif des institutions
juives de france contre la
multiplication des insultes antisémites
ou la profanation de cimetières juifs
le chef de l'état affiche sa fermeté le
temps est donc venu des actes emmanuel
macron réclament la dissolution de trois
groupuscule d'extrême droite mais
surtout une meilleure reconnaissance de
l'anti sionisme comme acte antisémite
l'antisionisme est une des formes
modernes de l'antisémitisme c'est
pourquoi je confirme que la france qui
comme vous l'avez rappelé l'a endossé en
décembre avec ses partenaires européen
mettra en oeuvre la définition de
l'antisémitisme adoptée par l'alliance
internationale pour la mémoire de la
shoah
un geste symbolique aucune modification
de la législation n'est prévu en
revanche le chef de l'état s'est engagé
dans une lutte contre la haine déversée
sur les réseaux sociaux des députés est
ici avia déposera dès le mois de mai
c'est à dire dès la première fenêtre
parlementaire possible au parlement une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre la
haine sur internet
l'objectif détecter et retirer plus
rapidement les propos haineux
sensibiliser les utilisateurs et
soutenir les victimes
une mesure inspirée d'une loi allemande
depuis 2018 les réseaux sociaux qui ne
retire pas les insultes dans les 24
heures risquent une amende pouvant
s'élever à 50 millions d'euros
bassin la chaux est ce que pour vous il
faut pénaliser l'antisionisme écoutez
c'est une question complexe parce que
les députés de la majorité ont dit on
dit oui le président a dit non
finalement la loi ne sera pas ne sera
pas modifié vous savez l'antisionisme
c'est aussi une opinion politique
il y à de nombreux juifs qui puisqu'il
se revendique anti anti sioniste donc je
pense que cela nécessite un une
réflexion plus approfondie que une
réaction à chaud sur un événement je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le droit
international reconnaît l'existence de
l'état d'israël cela ne pose pas
question cela c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut réaffirmer et dans le
même temps il doit toujours être
possible de critiquer la politique du
gouvernement israélien qui par exemple
vient d'adopter une loi créant deux
types de nationalité n'ayant avec en
fonction que l'on soit juif ou non avec
le des droits différents
donc je pense que il faut que l'on
puisse conserver le droit de critiquer
la politique de l'état d'israël
évidemment reconnaître là
les résolutions de l'onu de 1947 qui
crée l'état d'israël l on en vient notre
dernier thème bastien lachaud le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une revendication souvent émises
par les gilet jaune elle a été relayée à
l'assemblée nationale par la france
insoumise dans le cadre de sa niche
parlementaire le groupe a défendu une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour créer un rique proposer des lois
révoquer des élus dont le président de
la république réviser la constitution
le texte propose de donner plus de
pouvoir aux français mais il a été
repoussé sans ambages par la majorité
résumé des débats signée nathalie du
loir le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne n'aura pas aidé longtemps
débattu sur les bancs de l'assemblée
après trois heures de débats souvent
tendue soyez respectueux autant que les
gens vous aurez que les orateurs vous
ont respecté l'assemblée a rejeté la
proposition de loi d un sou ni sans même
examiner les articles
le groupe a tout juste eu le temps de
faire passer son message politique
le risque c'est la fin de la résignation
face aux combines électorale le risque
c'est la souveraineté retrouvée
le risque c'est le peuple qui prend en
main son propre destin
notre république est pourrie par des
institutions qui ont progressivement
dépouiller le peuple des moyens d'
exercice de sa souveraineté
le gouvernement lui dénoncé
l'opportunisme de la france insoumise
avec ce texte vous tentez en tirant
parti d'une crise grave de réintroduire
l'idée que nous devons changer de
république le gouvernement ne vous
suivra évidemment pas dans cette voie
car nos monsieur le rapporteur nous ne
pensons pas que notre république est
pourrie les échanges se tendent
quand la majorité déposent une motion de
renvoi en commission
apprenez à écouter apprenez à des bacs
apprenez amendé mais ne rejetez pas en
bloc les propositions des autres groupes
c'est précisément parce que ce débat a
lieu partout dans le pays que il
n'appartient pas à l'assemblée nationale
de le présenter de le récupérer et de
s'en faire le seul écho car même si
l'idée du riq bénéficie de peu de
soutiens à l'assemblée l'opposition
jugent le débat légitime
nous y sommes n'aurions pas le droit d
être d'un sujet qui intéresse les
français et c'est par ce qui les
intéresse les français que nous devons
en débattre
nous ne sommes peut-être pas d'accord
avec un certain nombre de formulation
qui sont présentes dans ce texte mais
nous souhaitons en débattre pour
défendre nos idées pour défendre les
idées pour lesquelles les français nous
ont élus cré zulte est la motion de
renvoi tout de même été adopté coupant
court à toute discussion
alors bastien et chaud sur la forme
d'abord comment jugez-vous le rejet de
ce texte en discussion de ces articles
par la majorité
c'est habituel c'est ce que fait la
majorité pour toutes les propositions
qui émanent d'autres rang que les siens
c'est une une autre forme de
l'autoritarisme de ce régime que que je
dénonçais c'est assez paradoxal on parle
du rich dans toute la france sur tous
les ronds-points dans les grands débats
etc et l'assemblée nationale le
parlement serait le seul endroit où l'on
n'aurait pas le droit d'en parler c'est
encore une fois la démonstration du peu
de cas que la république en marche fait
du parlement le président est tout
puissant et les citoyens mais rien du
pour le parlementarisme
parce que là encore cela pourrait être
une une forme de limitation des pouvoirs
du président ce que la république en
marche ne semble pas accepté le principe
du riz question du par 73 % des français
selon une enquête publiée cette semaine
emmanuel macron prendra un risque selon
vous a écarté cette mesure au moment des
conclusions le grand débat dans les
propositions qui seront retenus je pense
que plus qu'une proposition forte du
grand débat le ric est un moyen de
sortie par le haut du grand débat parce
que là les français débattent
c'est très bien les français sont un
peuple qui adore débattre qui a bordeaux
rediscuter et là des propositions
émergent qui va faire le tri entre ces
propositions
aujourd'hui ça va être le président tout
seul qui va faire ses propositions et
qui peut-être on apprend dans la presse
puis cela change qui va peut-être faire
un référendum pour soumettre aux
français c'est ces propositions mais le
souhaitez vous savez écouter
pourquoi pas un référendum mais la vraie
question c'est quelles questions vont
être posées au nom de quoi et macron
tout seul va décider avec le rique ce
que l'on proposé c'est que ce soit les
français eux mêmes qu'ils fassent les
questions auxquelles les français
eux-mêmes répondrai et là nous avons une
solution républicaines démocratiques
pacifiques de régler le pro
m de 7,2 de la crise des gilets jaunes
parce que les français discutent font
des propositions et rend chez eux mêmes
alors instauré le grec est ce que ce
n'est pas quand même affaiblir la
démocratie représentative est donc le
parlementaire que vous n'êtes pas du
tout c'est un c'est un complément c'est
complémentaire d'ailleurs là la vème
république prévoit à son article 3 que
la souveraineté nationale s'exprime par
le peuple par le biais de ses
représentants ou par le biais du
référendum
donc le référendum est un élément
d'expression de la souveraineté au même
titre que la démocratie représentative
et les parlementaires
donc cela ne change absolument pas
l'ordre des choses c'est juste que de
dire que aujourd'hui une seule personne
dans ce pays a droit de convoquer un
référendum c'est le président de la
république le risque c'était de dire des
citoyens peuvent également proposer un
référendum pour trancher cela ne change
absolument pas l'équilibré des pouvoirs
si ce n'est que cela renforce les
pouvoirs du peuple au détriment du
président de la république mais pour les
parlementaires cela ne change rien le
texte que vous proposiez proposait 2 %
des électeurs inscrits pour convoquer un
référendum ça fait à peu près neuf cent
mille personnes est ce que c'est
vraiment représentatifs l'un des dangers
est ce que serait pas de favoriser des
formes de groupes de pression
est-ce qu'on devrait pas revoter sous
tous les six mois sur le mariage
homosexuel par exemple écouter alors il
ya deux questions je les prendre une par
une sur les questions des seuils et
ensuite nous reviendrons sur la question
des droits fondamentaux
sur la question des seuils en italie
pour tout pouvoir abroger une loi
ces cinq cent mille signatures
nécessaires soit environ 1% et cela n'a
pas fait que l'italie s'est effondré ou
à voter tous les quatre matins il faut
bien penser qu'une chose un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
il va y avoir la phase de la collecte
des signatures c'est à dire que pendant
plusieurs mois les gens vont devoir
faire campagne pour obtenir c'est x
milliers de signatures peut-être 900
milles et ensuite il y aura une campagne
électorale
nous l'avions proposé de d'environ six
mois dans l'est dans les élections et
donc cela veut dire que pendant plus
d'un mois non le pays va réfléchir et va
débattre d'un sujet est donc dans sur la
question des droits fondamentaux j'ai
bien respectant j'y viens et donc
justement ce délai d'un an
je fais bien que l'on ne va pas
légiférer dans l'urgence
dans l'émotion mais que l'on va avoir le
temps d'un débat argumenté et réfléchie
et quand les gens ont un débat on
organise un débat réfléchit argumenté
ils peuvent trancher
sagement et sur les droits fondamentaux
dernière chose là nous avions demandé
lors de la réforme constitutionnelle de
juillet que ses droits soient
constitutionnaliser la république en
marche la refuser et aujourd'hui il
voudrait les protéger il y a là aussi
une peur du peuple qu'il faut dénoncer
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
investir la chaudanne cette semaine elle
merci thibault on se retrouve dans deux
semaines pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]